I'm Gerardo kapiel and I lead product
management for consumer payments here at
Google and with me is my partner in
crime brooch cotillion alright who's
excited here about Google paid today
[Applause]
great so earlier this year we unified
all the ways that you can pay with
Google into a single brand call Google
pay with Google pay you can play online
and at millions of places all around the
world with the payment information that
you saved in your Google account today
we're gonna be talking about the great
ways in which we're making it easier
faster and more rewarding for your
customers to check out online and in
stores we want to make payments easy for
everyone everywhere see who will pay is
not just an app Google pay makes
payments a foundational and integral
part of a Google users account so for
Google users logged in to any Google
service they can experience amazing
payment experiences that Google pay
provides the other advantage to tying
everything to one account is that
payment methods and transactions can all
be managed in a central location now we
all know that Mobile is the fastest
growing e-commerce surface but your
customers are transacting on all
surfaces so we want to make sure with
Google pay that you're that Google users
can pay ease as easily in stores with a
tap as they can online at your sites and
apps as well as on Google on Chrome on
YouTube Google Play and even Google
assistant
thanks for each so what's in it for all
you developers out here in the crowd
well currently there are hundreds of
millions of payment methods saved to
Google accounts when users transact on
play or when they saved our cards in
Chrome we know from operating Google
Play one of the world's largest
e-commerce marketplaces that these users
that have saved payment methods to their
account are much more likely to complete
a transaction than when they haven't and
we call these users ready to pay users
via our api's we're going to enable
these ready to pay users to also check
out quickly and easily in your own apps
and websites which means that you're
gonna see increased conversion rates
faster monetization and you'll be able
to provide your customers with the same
easy quick checkout experience that we
provide on Play now speaking of payment
methods let me turn to the Google pay
app so in an upcoming update of the
Google pay app we're gonna allow you to
manage all the payment methods in your
Google account not just the payment
methods that you use to pay in-store and
even better we're gonna provide you with
a holistic view of all your transactions
whether they be on Google Apps and
services such as play and YouTube
whether they be with third-party
merchants such as Walgreens and uber or
whether their transactions you've made
to friends and families via our
peer-to-peer service and of course the
app is available on Android but I'm
really excited to tell you all that
we're bringing this capability to iOS
and the web whoo
so let's dig a little deeper into the
Google payout so if you've opened the
app you come to a home tab that
hopefully many of you have seen this and
this tab is personalized for you based
on the credit and debit cards in your
Google account based on the loyalty
programs that you have saved to Google
pay based on the offers that you have
say to Google pay and even based on the
stores that are nearby you you can see
examples of the many types of cards that
you might find in the home feed of the
Google pay app now what's really
exciting is that some of these feed
cards are actionable so for example this
card that you see here allows you to
sign up for balanced rewards or if you
already belong it allows you to link
your balance rewards count to your
Google account and this card is geo
aware and so what that means is it only
shows up when you're at Walgreens so
that's what makes the Home tab so
personalized and great so merchants out
there and providers of loyalty programs
and offers programs that wish to take
advantage of these features to join the
ranks of the hundreds of partners that
have implemented the Google pay api's
for loyalty and to learn more I
encourage you to go the gqo slash pay
slash business now we're also working
with ticketing providers so that our
users can easily and quickly save event
tickets and boarding passes to their
Google account and then be able to
access them right in the Google pay app
I'm excited to announce some of our
early access partners some which I see
out here in the crowd such as Singapore
Airlines Southwest Eventbrite and
fortress GB who provides ticketing
infrastructure to major soccer leagues
in the UK and beyond so to talk more
about transit I'm going to turn it to
baruj yeah so loyalty and payments
covers most of what's in your wallet but
transit is a massive use case for our
Google users now Google pay already
supports transit and has for a while at
transit agencies that accept contactless
debit or credit cards so we see
transactions in London Chicago Kiev
Sydney Portland and coming soon and
Vancouver but if we only support
contactless debit or credit cards for
transit we'll be leaving a large portion
of our Google users that use traditional
transit tickets and passes underserved
and so we've been partnering with
transit technology providers like NXP
and it so to natively support these
traditional tickets and passes within
the Google Play app so you may have
heard recently that we launched in Las
Vegas as well as in Portland and today
we'd like to announce that coming soon
we'll have support and west midlands in
the UK so very very exciting now we're
working really hard on Google pay and
Google pay is already available to
hundreds of millions of users and
eighteen markets and I'm really proud to
say that just recently Google pay passed
100 million downloads in the Google Play
Store very cool but we're not stopping
there very soon we will be launching
many of the core features and the Google
pay app globally that means that
billions of Google users worldwide will
be able to leverage the
amazing payment experiences at Google
pay provides so we're very very excited
about this great it is super exciting
and users in the UK and the US have one
more thing to be excited about we are
bringing peer-to-peer payments right
into the Google pay app that means that
you'll be able to send and request money
directly from the app in the send tab
but even more exciting than that is that
you're gonna be able to easily split for
those those ticket that purchase for
tickets to the soccer game or the drinks
at the pub easily right from the Google
pay app so if you pull up the
transaction details after paying for
drinks at the pub right from there
you'll be able to split the expense with
your friends super exciting awesome
and guess what for many of these payment
experiences you don't even need to have
the Google pay app installed
for example our p2p experience is
already embedded in Gmail Android
contacts Google assistant Apple iMessage
and Android messages last year we
announced the ability for you through
your mobile banking app to provision a
debit or credit card into Google pay to
be able to use it in stores and online
this year we take it a step further with
our banking partners you can now sign up
for a new credit or debit card in the
mobile banking app have that provision
to Google pay and start using it even
before their credit a credit or debit
card arrives in the mail but also it's
pretty cool that is pretty cool and so
now that we've taken you through this
whirlwind tour of everything that's been
happening since we were last hope era
which has been dizzying and it's the
things that are making it easier simpler
and more rewarding for our users to pay
online and in stores let's talk about
the specific ways in which
you all here can create great
experiences for your customers online
and in stores so let's start with online
what I really like about online is its
scale there are millions and millions of
merchants all around the world where you
can buy things online and we want to
make every single one of those checkout
experiences great so that means that we
need solutions it's scale and the
ideally there's solutions where you
don't have to do anything or just do
very little chrome autofill is one of
those experiences chrome autofill
removes a hassle from users of having to
type in credit card numbers type in
shipping addresses and billing addresses
it makes it super simple so hopefully
your site already works perfectly with
chrome autofill but we know that there's
a number out there that don't so we want
to make sure that your users are able to
take advantage of autofill as best as
possible and we've published a set of
guidelines and best practices that will
enable you to test and optimize your
check out forms for chrome autofill to
learn more go to gqo slash pay slash
autofill or when you exit out of here
visit our sandbox right across the way
and speak with our engineers about how
you can optimize your checkout flow so
if we focused exclusively on autofill
we'd be doing Google users a disservice
the Northstar here is really to skip a
checkout form altogether and that's
where the Google pay API is for checkout
come in now we announce the online
payment API is last year but since then
we've made three
your enhancement and said I'd like to
talk to you about number one we're
announcing JavaScript bindings for the
google pay API for checkout that means
you can provide your customers with
great payment experiences that we will
pay provides across all browsers number
two in our API is we use a very
consistent JSON representation of the
request and response object what this
means is that if you implement the
Google pay API for a checkout for
example for web with JavaScript you can
easily port that including the payment
processing to your app and also to
Google assistant I actually want to show
you a quick demo here not not a demo but
screens here of what we've done with
Fandango that's coming soon where you
can actually get a very easy checkout
experience from Google search if when
you use a Google pay API for checkout
so a user searches for tickets on Google
com then they go to the Fandango site
where they can easily select and
purchase tickets using Google pay so
very exciting and the last thing that
last enhancement that I'd like to talk
about is that we've enhanced our is
ready to pay API with this API you can
tell whether a user on your site a
customer on your site it has payment
method that you can actually accept and
what this allows you to do is now that I
know you know that this is a ready to
pay user you can really streamline the
checkout experience and really drive
increased conversions great that's let's
pretty cool off in action but it's even
cooler when you see it in action let's
turn to the computer please great so
last year when we were up here we showed
you the great checkout experience that
we created on the web but it was limited
to
on Android I'm really excited that we've
now extended this to many other browsers
such as Safari both on desktop and iOS
Firefox and a number of browsers in edge
and Internet Explorer are coming soon
and you'll be able to play with this
yourselves right after this this slide
so I'm on our demo site time to get some
new Google gear so I like this shell
right here so I go to the product
details page and I see that there is a
buy with Google pay button and this is
good because you may not know this but
over 60% of online purchases are really
just for one item so why put users
through a multi-step checkout flow where
they have to add to a cart and all these
other steps let's just let them buy what
they want right directly from product
details so when I click there because I
was already logged into my Google
account since I was maybe checking my
Gmail or using YouTube whatever other
Google service Marta matically logged in
I see the payment methods that I've
saved to my Google account and other
information that's in my Google account
such as my shipping address and then I
just hit continue and voila I am done
it's that simple
ok so that's cool but on Chrome we're
doing something even more cool in the
near future so on Chrome we are creating
a near native experience that is fast
and seamless and tightly integrated into
Chrome as you can see right here when I
move my window around things stay in
place and this is really great let's
turn it back to the slides please so if
you want to check this out yourselves on
your iPhone or on your desktop go to G
dock o slash pay slash web demo ok so
fewer distractions
faster checkout simpler checkout means
greater conversion and we're pretty
confident that you're gonna see these
types of results when you implement the
Google pay API since we announced Google
pay the response from merchants has been
overwhelming all around the world we've
added merchants such as uber and
doordash ASOS deliver Roo and
soon-coming Starbucks
and our partners are seeing great
results StubHub for example since
they've implemented the newest version
of our API has seen a 7x increase in
transactions through Google pay and
Airbnb saw an 11 X increase in
transactions through Google pay and it's
also interesting that hotelTonight
interesting and great has found that
users that use Google pay to complete a
booking are 65% more likely to complete
the transaction that those who don't so
really really great results
super exciting brooch tell us more yeah
so if you guys take one thing away from
IO on the payment side you should
definitely figure out how you're going
to implement these Google pay api's for
check out on your surfaces to give your
customers incredible payment experiences
and we have two additional sessions that
you can go to the first is tomorrow
what's noon new for online checkout
that's on stage six and the second is by
our UX team it's called Google pay best
practices for great payment experiences
and that's on stage seven on Thursday so
please go out and check those out
great so let's talk next about something
that users love more than saving time
saving money who doesn't love to save
money so Google pay is more than just a
way to pay we've invested heavily in
making Google pay a platform by which
you can engage your users through
loyalty and offers in previous years
we've been up here and we've talked
about our smart app protocol which is
based on NFC and allows users when
they're in store to just tap once and
convey their loyalty credentials and
offers along with payment information
it's a great experience in merchants all
around the world have been being
implementing smart app and creating
great value added checkout experiences
for their users so I'm excited to
announce today that Russia's fur bank is
the latest partner that is going to be
rolling out smart app across thousands
of merchants in Russia and this is super
exciting brooch yeah but we're not just
stopping at loyalty and offers when it
comes smart app we're working with
tickets as well and in fact we have an
incredible demo today that we've done
with our partners at Ticketmaster that
brings together all the api's and smart
app into one demo so let's go to the
phone so you'll have to use your
imagination here let's all pretend we're
in Orlando so excuse the humidity and
I'm a massive soccer fan and my favorite
team is a Chicago Fire of the MLS so
Chicago Fire is visiting Orlando city SC
and I really want to check out this game
with Gerardo so I'm gonna open the
Ticketmaster up now since they're my
favorite team it'll be in favorites
so now I select the game I select a
ticket Dubai now
and here we see the BIOS Google pay
button so I'll give that a click
and I'll complete checkout boom I've
purchased these tickets gets better
though gets better
what's that I said it gets better gets
better yet so now I can view these
tickets and here we see the safety phone
buttons that gerardo mentioned so I can
save this ticket to Google pay so now
let's open the Google Play app when I go
to the cards I now notice that I have my
tickets here for Orlando SC versus
Chicago Fire and I'm all ready to go to
this game so I'm super excited get your
gear on but here's a kicker no pun
intended I can actually go to the gate
to get into the game and I don't need to
fiddle around with paper tickets and I
don't need to scan QR codes all I need
to do let's turn it to the ELMO thank
you
if top
and I've gained entry into the stadium
and I go along the way so these are the
incredible user journeys that we can
create together with these APL's
back to the slides
okay that was great
now that we've overloaded you with
information about all the great things
that you can do with Google pay what our
next steps so the first one is super
easy because it just takes a few steps
you exit out this door and you head over
to our sandbox and there you can meet
with the engineer is it have built all
these amazing things and you get you can
get your questions answered you can get
demos and some of the demos even get you
cookies and I'm not talking about
browser cookies like real tasty good
cookies oh man I'm getting hungry up
here yeah and as we've mentioned
throughout the presentation there are
several deep dives the rest of this week
into the different things that we talked
about today first of all all right
encourage you to go check out tomorrow
night at 6:30 on this stage the what's
new for online checkout session which is
going to be run by one of our PM's and
one of the engineers that have built all
this amazing things then on Thursday our
payments UX team is going to be doing a
session on best practices for creating
great checkout flows and they're gonna
talk touch upon many of the things that
we talked about today but really go a
lot deeper and beyond and then finally
on Thursday afternoon right near here on
stage five you can learn about how you
can add transactional capabilities to
your actions so if you can make these
sessions or the sandbox or if you're
watching on live stream and you want to
learn more these are some of the
resources you can go to Jeju Coast slash
pay / ro Phil will give you best
practices on how to optimize your site
for autofill geo / paste slash business
we'll give you an overview of everything
we've discussed today and if you're a
developer and you just want to jump
right into the API documentation please
go to gqo slash pay slash developers to
get the API documentation directly
it's going backwards so I one of me I
want to say thank you to all the
developers and the development come in
the developer community in the room
really these payment experiences or a
partnership between us we can't provide
these payment experiences to your
customers without you and so thank you
very much for coming today and thank you
for working with us in developing these
incredible experiences together with
Google pay thank you thank you very much
[Music]
you